sur l'est de l'ukraine c'est le message
qu'a martelé le président de la
république emmanuel macron à la fois en
russie est aujourd'hui à kiev il n'y a
pas d'autre possibilité il n'y a pas
d'autres cadres dans lequel négocier ce
qui doit se passer à l'est de l'ukraine
la solution ne peut être que politique
et elle passe par l'application stricte
c'est ce qu'il a dit aujourd'hui de
l'accord de minsk donc emmanuel macron
déterminé à faire bouger
cet accord qui effectivement a passé
plusieurs mois au point mort complet
entre 2019 et puis le 26 janvier de
cette année où il ya eu effectivement
réaffirmation d'une volonté d'avancer
dans ce cadre donc selon emmanuel macron
et c'est ce qu'on a entendu aujourd'hui
il a reçu des garanties à la fois des de
vladimir poutine et de volleyball du
maire zelensky qu'il y avait une volonté
d'avancer dans ce cadre là maintenant il
faut voir bien sûr qu' il y a beaucoup
de problèmes à régler notamment la
lectures divergentes de cet accord par
les deux parties les russes et les
ukrainiens côté ukrainien il y avait un
certain nombre de lignes rouges qui ont
clairement été édictée notamment le fait
par exemple que ici on dit qu'il n'y
aura pas de négociations directes avec
les séparatistes
inféodés à moscou de la même manière il
a été dit aussi qu'il est extrêmement
difficile puisqu'il faudrait pour offrir
une autonomie à ces deux provinces que
sont loin et donne y est qu'il faudrait
une modification constitutionnelle
là aussi c'est quelque chose qui risque
d'être extrêmement compliqué et
volodymyr des landes ce qui le sait très
bien sur la scène intérieure en matière
de politique intérieure ces mesures là
sont extrêmement impopulaire et pourrait
mener à des difficultés dans le pays
bref il y a certainement beaucoup de
choses à négocier cela va continuer dans
d'ici quelques jours en allemagne avec
une réunion fort made in normandie c'est
à dire france allemagne russie et
l'ukraine james concernant le statut de
l'ukraine qui souhaitent rejoindre
l'otan depuis longtemps il n'y a pas eu
d'avancée
alors à priori non on ne sait pas
exactement ce qu emmanuel macron a dit
hier à vladimir poutine puisque vladimir
poutine a dit qu'effectivement il y
avait possibilité de construire à partir
de ce qu'avait proposé le chef de l'état
français mais on n'a pas eu plus de
précisions nous explique effectivement
que c'est un processus long complexe
qu'il y aura de longues négociations
emmanuel macron qui appelle à être
créatifs et à être constructif dans
cette construction d'une nouvelle europe
de la sécurité en tout cas il ya un mois
aujourd'hui une question qui a été posée
par une consoeur journaliste qui a parlé
de la fameuse finlandisation de
l'ukraine alors pour rappel il
s'agissait de la finlande à l'époque de
l'urss qui finalement était dans une
situation elle avait une certaine
autonomie en matière de politique
intérieure mais suivait l'urss en
matière de politique extérieure de
manica this de manière quasiment
systématique c'était évidemment une
grosse perte de souveraineté pour la
finlande à l'époque est bien et il avait
été question par certains observateurs
que cela pourrait arriver bien la
question a été posée à emmanuel macron
et bien sa réponse a été très clair il a
dit voilà ce n'est pas une option ce
n'est pas sur la table et il n'a même
pas voulu prononcer le mot du côté de
volodymyr est né ce qui pas plus de
précisions si ce n'est qu'on a appris
durant cette conférence de presse est
bien qu'il n'avait pas regardé la
conférence de presse conjointe entre le
président russe vladimir poutine
emmanuel macron il avait dit qu'il était
trop occupé pour l'heure regarder ce qui
est malgré tout ainsi assez fort de la
manière dont il prend les tractations en
cours bref une europe de la sécurité à
construire selon emmanuel macron et
évidemment quelques concessions quand
même selon le président français à
savoir qu'il a expliqué que le président
poutine a garanti qu'il n'y aurait pas
de base
construite en biélorussie et qu'il n'y
aurait pas non plus de déploiement
d'armes sensible emmanuel maintenant est
attendue